for some Sudanese refugees and camps in
Chad fear is turning to anger eager to
talk about the injustices they are
facing many are unable to speak without
crying
Usman was separated from his family when
fighting broke out in al-janaina in
westar4 he searched for weeks before
crossing the border people whom are
engineered now they are suffering from
every side they are not there is no food
there is no medicine there is no place
to go there is no place to go to go to
get water I want to send my message to
help those people he lost a hand in a
previous conflict and says if he doesn't
find his family he will do the
unthinkable and go back
to streets lined with the dead to risk
meeting the same fate
this territory the gunman says is now
under militia control
those who've worked in Darfur for
decades blame political neglect a
collapse of State Authority and previous
governments who armed certain
communities for their own political gain
the war in Khartoum is a classic battle
between two rival forces in a struggle
for power in Darfur and especially in
elginina it is much more existential
between communities it goes to the
struggle for land for water for use of
Natural Resources precious metals and
minerals refugees say al-jinena is the
worst place in the world
is an African Mass elite leader he says
the city is home to dozens of tribes but
one is being singled out and persecuted
if you see in cartoon RSA fight with
stuff
but in alginena RSA fight against
masarit and black people
daily we lose more than 50. people daily
daily
says he will return to defend his
hometown or die trying
on street level it is obvious that more
and more people are arriving from Sudan
on a daily basis the refugees we speak
to say while it is true that the
militias are targeting one specific
tribe at the moment the violence is so
widespread it is affecting everybody
U.N calls for a ceasefire have been
drowned out by the sounds of War
Aid groups worry the ongoing violence
could spread across the region the
masalit warn if the militias are not
stopped other tribes could be targeted
next Zain basavi al-jazeera Audrey
Eastern Chad